the council should change the
procedure to be able to adopt the
multiannual budget by a
qualified majority and not unanimously because it
is unfair that 23 countries, but Europeans,
are hostage to 4 that prefer
national responses to me apart from
lack of solidarity seems to me to be a
really short-sighted attitude because  we only
have to look around
us to realize that multilateralism
is at risk and that we need
global governance this is the moment
of truth to put the cards on the
table we want to continue building a
political union because this goes
beyond  solidarity and because
we must also assume that in this
increasingly turbulent world it is worth working
to defend the European project, that is why it
is essential, Mrs von der Leyen, that you
maintain your proposal to change the
European semester, we must overcome the
logic of fiscal consolidation, not
we can put conditions to
cut pensions we have to put conditions  ones
to advance
environmental and
social sustainability mrs von der layen we have already seen that
here in the european parliament you have a
project willing to always work
for the good of the citizenry now it is your
turn to convince the friends of the council
be firm be ambitious and we  will have on
his side we owe it to the next
generations of the european union
always free